what's so special about his talk it's a
tall chair I guess about 2500 mm well I
actually made the chest I can tell you a
little bit more about it but it's a
little bit more expensive than that
because it's it's all hand carved it's
made from mahogany and it takes a long
time to make these that she ranges from
7,000 to $14,000 depending on the fabric
that you have unless you have diamonds
on it there's gonna get a lot more
expensive
I definitely research you I didn't even
realize that I was gonna meet you today
some real fans got a really no [ __ ]
I did not know I was gonna meet him and
I really got him on my iPad I've been
looking at his furniture like [ __ ] how
do you come up with somebody new stuff
that you'd be creatively where do you
get this stuff wrong I think one of the
ideas was you know to do something
different I left London 22 years ago
that was in the deep trouble I thought
you were steel yeah I just happened to
be here and this morning I heard you
were coming here and then I said well
can we meet up and this is how it all
came together so it was a bit of luck
you brought some of your pieces here are
they were already here no they weren't
actually we brought them over especially
for you well you know might even put
this collection together it's actually
cool the members art collection and the
moselle reason for that it's because I
always loved the French fashion
designers they love that I had for the
French fashion houses co-efficient al I
said well what if I was to imagine what
her home would look like and then I
could do a range a lifestyle look as if
it was the home of Coco Chanel so that's
why it looks like it does
that vile furniture so man amazed it's
really an honor for me to meet you
personally and know that you take a year
to make something and then I think about
this chair
it may be worth that kind of money you
know I mean the craftsmanship the
mahogany I'm just gonna need like every
other rich person in the world a
discount yeah how that works why does it
work that way
the discouraged people get stuff for
free baby you know I got really so which
of these pieces of you like Oh we'd like
some of each on the catalog you can
choose yeah maybe I exchange it for you
know they sure that'd be great
well then we'll need a picture of you in
bed shirt off lil you know I'm safe for
Saachi ball you know I'm saying with the
oatmeal in the passatti bowl with the
Christopher guy headboard now for real
with the verse a slippers is anybody
seeing this but me this is some GQ [ __ ]
this is some GQ [ __ ] real
[Music]